it appears as though Donald Trump was
notified by his lawyers yesterday after
their meeting with the justice
department that he will almost certainly
be getting arrested and charged
federally Donald Trump immediately took
to his social media platform truth
social
where he ranted about how other
presidents Obama haven't been arrested
or indicted I guess for the crimes Trump
may have committed you've got to see
this mostly with caps lock engaged
Donald Trump posting after his lawyers
gave him the bad news quote how can doj
possibly charge me who did nothing wrong
when no other presidents were charged
there's an apostrophe on presidents we
don't know why it's a it that's a
totally woke apostrophe we're not going
to do the woke grammar in Florida where
if you do the apostrophe when you
actually don't mean possessive you mean
plural we're just not gonna do it
teachers won't be allowed will will fire
him right away okay when no other
presidents were charged when Joe Biden
won't be charged for anything including
the fact that he has 850 boxes much of
it classified and some dating back to
his Senate day when even Democrat
senators are shocked also President
Clinton had documents and one in court
crooked Hillary deleted 33 000 emails
many classified and wasn't even close to
being charged only Trump the greatest
Witch Hunt of all time
so
Trump Furious that other presidents
haven't been charged
for the crimes Trump committed okay this
morning getting even more Bonkers on
truth
ing out a lot of agit trash including
quote the marxists and fascists in the
doj and FBI are going after me at a
level and speed never seen before in our
Capital C country and I did nothing
wrong first question can we identify a
single FBI Marxist after years of
talking about it do we know of a single
Marxist in the doj Trump continuing Joe
Biden kept keeps thousands of documents
in many locations some illegally taken
from Skiffs while he was a Senator a big
portion of which were classified he
didn't want to give them back and still
doesn't nothing happens to him with same
reasonable prosecutor who correctly
exonerated Mike Pence I have a much
different prosecutor a trump hater then
Trump going in the direction of saying
it's all about impacting Trump's 24 run
saying quote it's all about election
interference they don't want to run
against me I ran twice I did much better
the second time getting millions and
millions more votes than the first a
record for a sitting president and them
leading Biden in the polls by a lot they
are the capital P party of capital D
disinformation they are using the doj
and FBI against me to capital r double G
rig that's a doozy capital r double G
rig the 2024 election they'll hit Hunter
with something small to make their
strike on me look Fair nothing about
these capital F fascists is fair or
honest fight
these things are almost impossible to
read and then lastly
as of an hour ago although he probably
has posted more quote they are also
going after me as retribution for the
republicans in Congress going after them
the difference is they have created
Major Crimes I have created none now for
many of you wondering did we get to the
bottom of Obama gate the biggest
political crime of the century As Trump
once said no we still don't know what
Obama gate is and so the questions about
why Clinton or Obama or hunter or
whoever haven't been charged it appears
as though at this time
there is not evidence of criminality
period that would be the reason Trump
melting down on Troth Central we can
only hope that Justice is done
did people hear that notice how I'm not
saying I hope Trump is thrown in prison
and they throw away the key blah blah
blah what I'm saying is I hope that if
the evidence points to criminality
Justice is done
that's called Law and Order okay not
lock this person up despite no evidence
of criminality not lock that person up
or kill people
execute people even absent to guilty
verdict no it is I hope that there if
there is evidence nobody is above the
law all of these posts from truth will
be on our Instagram they will be on Tick
Tock and they will certainly be on
Facebook that I promise you if you or
one of your parents is starting to lose
your hearing you're not alone about 48
million Americans have hearing loss and
only one in five people who would
benefit from using a hearing aid are
actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearings new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearing's smallest hearing aid
ever no one will even know that it's
there I have a close family friend who
uses MD hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with a 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special deal for my audience when you
buy a pair of hearing aids you'll get
them for just 149.99 each plus they'll
include a free extra charging case go to
mdhearing.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below